welcome to
classification in machine learning my
name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team
that's www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead classification
is probably one of the most widely used
tools in machine learning in today's
world
and is also one of the simpler versions
to start understanding how a lot of
machine learning works
we're going to start by taking a look at
what exactly
is classification the important
terminologies around classification
we'll look at some real world
applications my favorite
popular classification algorithms and
there are a lot out there so we're only
going to touch briefly on a variety of
them so you can see how the different
flavors work
and we'll have some hands-on demos in
python embedded throughout the tutorial
classification classification is a task
that requires the use of machine
learning algorithms to learn
how to assign a class label to a given
data
you can see in this diagram we have our
unclassified data
it goes through a classification
algorithms and then you have classified
data
it's hard to just see it as data and
that really is where
you kind of start and where you end when
you start
running these machine learning
algorithms and classification
and the classification algorithms is a
little black box
in a lot of respects and we'll look into
that you can see what i'm talking about
when we start swapping in and out
different models
let's say we are given the task of
classifying a given bunch of fruits and
vegetables on the basis of their
category
i.e fruits are to be grouped together
and vegetables are to be grouped
together
and so we have a data set we'll call it
the bunch is divided into clusters
one of which consists of the fruits
while the other has
the vegetables you can actually look at
this as any kind of data
when we talk about breast cancer can we
sort out an images
to see what is malignant what is benign
very popular one can you classify
flowers the iris data set
certainly in wildlife can you classify
different animals and track where
they're going
classification is really the bottom
starting point or the baseline for a lot
of machine learning
and setting it up and trying to figure
out how we're going to break the date up
so we can use it
in a way that is beneficial so here the
fruits and the vegetables are
grouped into clusters and each clusters
has a specific
characteristic i.e whether they are a
fruit or a vegetable
and you can see we have a pile of fruits
and vegetables we feed it into the
algorithm and the algorithm separates
them out and you have fruits and
vegetables
so some important terminologies before
we dig into how it sorts them out and
what that all means
uh we look at the terminologies you have
a
classifier that's the algorithm that is
used to map the input data to a specific
category the classification model the
model that predicts or draws a class to
the
input data given for training feature it
is an individual
measurable property of the phenomena
being observed
and labels the characteristics on which
the data points of a data set are
categorized
the classifier and the classification
model go together
a lot of times the classifier is part of
the classification model
and then you choose which classifier you
use after you choose which model you're
using
where features are what goes in labels
are what comes out
so your classifier model is right in the
middle of that that's that little black
box we were just talking about
clusters they are a group of data points
which have some
common characteristics binary
classification it is a classification
condition
with two outcomes which are either true
or false
multi-label classification this is a
classification condition where each
sample is assigned to a set of labels or
targets multi-class classification the
classification with more than two
classes
here each sample is assigned to one and
only one
label when we look at this group of
terminologies a few important things to
notice
going from the top clusters
when we cluster data together we don't
necessarily have to have an
end goal we just want to know what
features cluster together
these features then are mapped to the
outcome we want
in many cases the first step might not
even care about the outcome
only about what data connects with other
data and there's a lot of clustering
algorithms out there that do just the
clustering part
binary classification it is a
classification condition with two
outcomes which are either true
or false we're talking usually it's a
it's either a cat or it's not a cat it's
either a dog
or it's not a dog that's the kind of
thing we talk about binary
classification
and then that goes into multi-label
classification think of label as you can
have
an object that is brown you can have an
object that is labeled as a dog
so it has a number of different labels
that's very different than a multi-class
classification where each one's a binary
you can either be a cat or a dog you
can't be both a cat
and a dog real world applications
so to make sense of this of course the
challenge is always in the details is to
understand how we apply this in the real
world
so in real world applications we use
this all the time we have email spam
classifier
so you have your email inbox coming in
it goes through the email filter that we
usually don't see in the background
and it goes this is either valid email
or it's a spam and it puts it in the
spam filter if that's what it thinks it
is
alex's voice classifier google voice any
of the voice classifiers
they're looking for points so they try
to group words together and then they
try to find those group
so words trigger a class a classifier so
it might be
that the classifier is to open your
tasks program
or open your text program so you can
start sending a text
sentimental sentiment analysis is really
big
when we're tracking products we're
tracking marketing
trying to understand uh whether
something is liked or disliked is huge
that's like one of the biggest driving
forces in cells nowadays
and you almost have to have these
different filters going on
if you're running a large business of
any kind fraud detection
you can think of banks they find
different things on your bank statement
and they detect that there's something
going on there
they have algorithms for tracking the
logs on computers they start finding
weird logs on computers they might find
a hacker
i mentioned the cat and dog so here's
our image classification
we have a neighbor who runs an outdoor
webcam
and we like to have it come up with a
classification when the wild animals in
our area are
out like foxes we actually have a
mountain lion that lives in the area so
it's nice to know when he's here
handwriting prediction classifying a b c
d and then classifying words to go with
that so let's go ahead and
roll our sleeves up and take a look at
some popular classification algorithms
before we look at the algorithms let's
go back and take a look at our
definitions
we have a classifier and a
classification
model so we're looking at the classifier
an algorithm that is used to map the
input data to a specific
category one of those algorithms is a
logistic
regression the logistic regression is a
classification algorithm used to model
the probability of a certain class or
event
existing such as pass fail or win lose
etc
it provides its output using the
logistic function or
sigmoid function to return the
probability value that can
then be mapped to two or more discrete
classes
a sigmoid function is an activation
function that fits
the variable and limit the output to a
range between
0 and 1. a standard sigmoid function or
logistic function is represented by the
formula
f x equals 1 over 1 plus e to the minus
x where x is the equation of the line
and e
is the exponential just taking a quick
look at this
you can think of this as being a point
of uncertainty
and so as we get closer and closer to
the middle of the line
it's either activated or not and we want
to make that just
shoot way up uh so you'll see a lot of
the activation from this kind of have
this nice s
curve where it approaches one and
approaches zero
and based on that there's only a small
region of error
and so you can see in the sigmoid
logistic function uh the one over one
plus e minus
x to the minus x you can see it frames
that that nice
s curve uh we also can use a tangent
variation there's a lot of other
different
models here as far as the actual
algorithm
this is the most commonly used one let's
go ahead and roll up our sleeves and
take a look
at a demo that is going to use a
logistic regression so we're going to
have the
activation formula and the model because
you have to have you have to have both
for this we will go into our jupiter
notebook
now i personally use the anaconda
navigator
to open up the jupiter notebook to set
up my ide as a web-based
it's got some advantages that it's very
easy to display in
but it also has some disadvantages in
that
if you're trying to do multi-threads and
multi-processing you start running into
a single get issues with python and then
i jump to
pycharm really depends on whatever id
you want just make sure you've installed
numpy and the sklearn modules into your
python
in whatever environment you're working
in so that you'll have access to that
for this demo
now the team in the back has prepared my
code for me which i'll start bringing
in one section at a time so we can go
through it before we do that
it's always nice to actually see where
this information is coming from and what
we're working with
so the first part is we're going to
import our packages
which you need to install into your
python and that's going to be your numpy
we usually use numpy as np and then from
sklearn
the learn model we're going to use a
logistic regression
and from sk learn metrics we're going to
import the classification report
confusion matrix
and if we go ahead and open up s the
scikit-learn.org and go under their api
you can see all the different features
and models they have
and we're looking at the linear model
logistic regression
one of the more common classifiers out
there and if we go ahead and go into
that and dig a little deeper
you'll see here where they have the
different settings it even says right
here
note the regularization is applied by
default so by default that is the
activation
formula being used now we're not going
to spin we might come back to this look
at some of the other models it's always
good to see what you're working with
but let's go ahead and jump back in here
and we have our imports we're going to
go ahead and run those
so these are now available to us as we
go through our jupiter notebook
script and they put together a little
piece of data for us this is simply um
going through zero to one actually let's
go ahead and print this out over here
we'll go ahead and print
x just so you can see we're actually
looking for and when we run this you can
see that we have our x is zero one
two through nine we reshaped it the
reason for this is just looking for a
row of data
usually we have multiple features we
just have the one feature which happens
to be zero through nine
and then we have our ten answers right
down here
uh zero one zero zero one one one one
one you can bring in
a lot of different data depending on
what you're working with you can make
your own you can instead of having this
as just a single you could actually
have like multiple features in here but
we just have the one feature for
this particular demo and this is really
where all the magic
happens right here and i told you it's
like a black box that's the part that is
is kind of hard to follow and so if you
look right here we have our model
we talked about the model right there
and then we went ahead and set it for
library linear as i showed you earlier
that's actually default so it's not that
important
uh random state equals zero this stuff
you don't worry too much about
and then with the scikit learn you'll
see the model fit
this is very common to scikit they use
similar stuff in a lot of other
different packages
but you'll you'll see that that's very
common you have to fit your data
and that means we're just taking the
data and we're fitting our x
right here which is our features that's
our x
and here's y these are the labels we're
looking for
so before we were looking at is it fraud
is it not is it cat
is it not that kind of thing and this is
looking at zero ones we want to have a
binary set up on this and we'll go ahead
and run this
you can see right here it just tells us
what we loaded it with as our defaults
and that
this model has now been created and
we've now fit our data to it
and then comes the fun part you work
really hard to clean your data to
bake it and cook it there's all kinds of
i don't know why they go with the
cooking terms as far as how we get this
data formatted
then you go through and you pick your
model you pick your solver
and you have to test it to see hey which
one's going to be best
and so we want to go ahead and evaluate
the model and you do this is it once
you've
figured out which one is going to work
the best for you you want to evaluate it
so you can compare it to your last model
and you can either update it to create a
new one or maybe change the
solver to something else i mentioned
tangent that's one of the other
common ones that's commonly used with
language for some reason the tangent
even though it looks almost to me
identical to
the one we're using with the sigmoid
function uh if for some reason it
activates better with language even
though it's a very small
shift in the actual math behind it we
already looked at the
data early but we're going to look at it
again just you can see we look at we
have
our rows of 01 row it only has one
entity
and we have our output that matches
these rows and these do have to match
you'll get an error if you put in
something with a different shape so if
you have
ten rows of data and nine answers it's
going to give you an error because you
need to have 10 answers for it
a lot of times you separate this too
when you're doing larger models
but for this we're just going to take a
quick look at that the first thing we
want to start looking at is uh the
intercept
one of the features inside our linear
regression model
we'll go ahead and run that and print it
you'll see here we have an intercept of
minus
1.516 and if we're going to look at the
intercept we should also look at our
coefficients
and if you run that you'll see that we
get a we get the
our coefficient is the 0.7035 you can
just think of this as your euclidean
geometry for
very basic model like this where it
intercepts the y at some point and we
have a coefficient multiplying by it a
little more complicated in the back end
but that is the
of this simple model which is the one
feature in there
and we'll go ahead and reprint the y
because i want to put them on top of
each other with the y predict
and so these were the y values we put in
and this is the y
predict we had coming out and you can
see um yeah here we go
there's the white actual and there's
what the prediction comes in
now keep in mind that we used the
actual complete data as part of our
training
that is if you're doing a real model a
big stopper right there because you
can't really see how good it did unless
you split some data off
to test it on this is the first step is
you want to see how your model actually
test on the data you trained it with and
you can see here
there is this point right here where it
has it wrong and this point right here
where it also has it wrong
and it makes sense because we're going
our input is 0 1
0 through 9 and it has to break it
somewhere and this is where the break is
so it says this half the data is going
to be 0 because that's what it looked
like to me if i was looking at it
without an algorithm and this data is
probably going to be 1.
and i i didn't i forgot to point this
out so let's go back up here i just kind
of glanced over
this window here we did a lot of stuff
let's go back and and just take a look
at that
what was done here is we ran a
prediction uh so this is where our
predict comes in
is our model.predict so we had a model
fit
we created the model we programmed it to
give us the right answer
now we go ahead and predict what we
think it's going to be
there's our model that predict
probability of x and then we have
our y predict which is very similar but
this has to do more with the probability
numbers
so if you remember down below we had the
setup where we're looking at uh that
sigmoid function
that's what this is returning and the y
predict is returning a 0 or a 1.
and then we have our confusion matrix
we'll look at that
and we have our report which just
basically compares our y to our y
predict which we just did
it's kind of nice a simple data so it's
really easy to see what we're doing
that's why we do
use the simple data this can get really
complicated when you have
a lot of different features and things
going on in splits
uh so here we go we've had our i printed
out our actual and our prediction so
this is the actual data this is what the
predict ran
and then we'll go ahead and do we're
going to print out the confusion matrix
we were just talking about that this is
great if you have a lot of
data to look at but you can see right
here a confusion matrix says
if you remember from the confusion
matrix we have the two
this is two correct one two
and uh it's been a while since i looked
at a confusion matrix
there's the two and then we have this
one which is our six
that's where the six comes from and then
we have this one
which is the one false
this is the two ones so we have this one
here and this one here which is
misclassified
this really depends on what data you're
working with as to what you're
is important you might be looking at
this model
and if this model this confusion matrix
comes up
and says that you misclassified
even one person as being non-malignant
cancer that's a bad model i wouldn't
want that classification i'd want this
number to be
zero i wouldn't care if this false
positive was off by a little bit more
long as i knew that i was correct on
the important factor that i don't have
cancer so you can see that this
confusion matrix really aims you in the
right direction
of what you need to change in your model
how you need to adjust it
and then there's of course a report
reports are always nice
if you notice we generated a report
earlier we'll go and just print the
report up and you can remember this is a
report it's a classification report
y comma why predict so we're just
putting in our two values
basically what we did here visually with
our actual
and our predicted value and we'll go
ahead and run the report
and you can see it has the precision the
recall your f1 score your support
translated into a accuracy macro average
and weighted average
so it has all the numbers a lot of times
when working with clients
or with the shareholders in the company
this is really where you start
because it has a lot of data and they
can just kind of stare at it and try to
figure it out
and then you start bringing in like the
confusion matrix i almost do this
in reverse as to what they show i would
never show your shareholders the
intercept of the coefficient
that's for your internal team only
working on machine language
but the confusion matrix and the report
are very important those are the two
things you really want to be able to
show on these
and you can see here we did a decent job
of
classifying the data managed to get a
significant portion of it correct
we had our was the accuracy here is a
0.80 f1 score
that kind of thing so you know it's a
pretty accurate model of course this is
pretty
goofy because it's very simple model and
it's just splitting the
model between ones and zeros so that was
our
demo of the um on logistic regression on
there
let's go and take a look at k nearest
neighbors
uh this one is another very highly used
and important
algorithm to understand k nearest
neighbors is a simple algorithm which
stores all available cases and
classifies new cases
based on the similarity measure the k
nearest neighbor
finds out the class of the new data
point by finding its nearest
neighbors if there are three data points
of class a
and two data points of class b near to
the new data point then the k n
classifies the new data point as class a
the k in k nearest neighbors is the
number of nearest neighbors we are
looking for our year i.e if we
say k equals 3 this means that we are
looking for nearest three neighbors of
unclassified data point usually we take
the k value between 3 to 10
as it leads to a better result a smaller
value of k means
that noise will have a bigger influence
on the result
and a larger value of k makes it
computationally
expensive hence the data scientists
prefer the range of k between
3 and 10. when we talk about noise
remember the data we just looked at was
zero one one zero zero
it had some some values were cut it and
said everything to the right is a one
everything to the left is a zero
but i had some ones and zeros mixed in
there that's called noise that's what
they're talking about is there's some
things that
are right in the middle in the
classification which makes it very hard
to classify
so suppose we're trying to find the
class for a new point
indicated by the red color and you can
see it's kind of right between the cat
right between the dogs let k equal 3 so
we are finding
the 3n in for the red data point by
looking at the plot on the right we can
see that the red data point belongs to
the class
dogs as it has two votes for class dog
and one vote
for class cat and if you ask the
question
well what are you measuring the distance
what is that distance
um it could be the measurements of the
ears whether they're pointed or floppy
that might be one of the features you're
looking at is how floppy the ears are
another one might be the whiskers versus
the nose
and then you take those measurements and
using
the one the most common things in k
means
measurement is the euclidean geometry
you can figure out the distance between
those points
there's a lot of different algorithms
for that but you can think about it that
you do have to have some kind of solid
data to measure
and so we can conclude that the new data
point belongs to the class
dog so let's go ahead and see what this
looks like in code and do a
demo on the k nearest neighbors in here
and we'll go right back into
our jupiter notebook and open up a new
python programming script page of course
once we're in here we'll want to look at
the
site kit learn i did just a quick search
for sk
neighbors kn neighbors classifier this
actually is the older version
0.01.023 is the one we want and you'll
see here that we have all their defaults
in neighbors equals five at defaults we
were talking about that between three
and ten
there's different ways to weigh it
there's an algorithm based on it i
mentioned euclidean geometry finding the
distance there's other algorithms for
figuring out what that distance is and
how to weight those
uh there's a lot of other parameters you
can adjust
for the most part the k means uh basic
setup is a good place to start and just
let the defaults go
we might play with some of those we'll
see what the guys in the back did
and from here we're going to import
numpy we're going to use pandas
if you haven't been running pandas
pandas is our data frame which sits on
top of numpy's
data frames are you know numpy's is our
number array
pandas is our data frame matplot library
because we're going to plot some graphs
everybody likes some pretty pictures it
makes it a lot easier to see what's
going on when you have
a nice display and that's also what the
seaborne is in here
in the setup that sits on top of the
matplot library
the ones we really want to look at right
here are the
what we're bringing in from sk learn
these ones right here
uh so from sklearn we're gonna load i
mentioned
the breast cancer that's a very popular
one because it has
i believe it's 36 measurements so
there's 36 features
and unless you're a expert you're not
going to know what any of those features
really mean
you can sort of guess but their special
measurements they take of when they take
a
image and of course our confusion matrix
so that we can take a look and see what
the data looks like and how good we did
and then we have our kn neighbors
classifier on here
uh and then i mentioned that uh whenever
you do
training and testing you want to split
the data up
you don't want to train the data and
then test it on the same data
that just tells you how good your
training model is it doesn't tell you
whether it actually works on
unknown data and so this just splits it
off so that we can train it and then we
can take a look at data we don't have in
there
and see how good it did and we'll go
ahead and load our
data up so here's our setup on that
oops there we go so we're going to go
ahead and load the date up
we have our x value and that's going to
come from our
breast cancer.data and call them breast
cancer feature names
so there's our actual all our different
features
we'll print that out here in a second
and then we have our
mean area mean compactness so i guess
we're going to
take the data and we're only going to
use a couple of the
columns this just makes it easier to
read
of course when you actually we're going
to do this you'd want to use all your
columns
and then we have our y and this is
simply
whether it's either malignant or b9
and then we want to go ahead and drop
the first line
because that's how it came in on there
and we'll go ahead let's just take a
look at this a little closer here let's
go and run this real quick
and just because i like to see my data
before i run it
we can look at this and we can look at
the original features remember only
going to use two features off of here
just to make it a little easier to
follow
and here's the actual data and you can
see that this is just
this massive stream of data coming in
here
it's going to just skip around there's
so much in there to set up i think
there's like 500 if i remember correctly
and you can see here's all the different
measurements they take but we don't we
don't really need to see that on here
we're just going to take a look at just
the two columns
and then also our solution we'll go
ahead and just do a quick uh
print y on here so you can see what the
y looks like
and it is simply just zero zero zero you
know b
nine zero zero zero one so a one means
it's b nine to zero means it's malignant
uh that's what we're looking at on that
cut that out of there
the next stage is to go ahead and split
our data
i mentioned that earlier we'll just go
ahead and let them do the splitting
forest
for us we have x train x test y
train y test and so we go ahead and
train test split
x y random state equals 1. it makes it
nice and easy for us
we'll go and run that and so now we have
our training and our testing
train means we're going to use that to
train the model and then we're going to
use the test to test to see how good our
model does
and then we'll go ahead and create our
model here's our knn model
the k neighbors classifier in neighbors
equals five
the metrics is euclidean remember i
talked about euclidean
this is simply your c squared equals a
squared plus b
squared plus a squared equals b squared
plus c squared plus c
squared plus d squared and then you take
the square root of all that that's what
they're talking about here it's just the
length of the
hypotenuse of a triangle but you can
actually do that multiple dimensions
just like you do in two dimensions with
a regular triangle and here we have our
fit
this should start to look familiar since
we already did that in our last example
that's very standard for s scikit
and any other one although sometimes the
fit algorithms look a little bit more
complicated because they're doing more
things on there especially when you get
into neural networks
uh and then you have your k neighbors it
just tells you we created a
k neighbors setup they kind of wanted us
to reformat the y but it's not that big
of a deal for this
and it comes out and shows you that
we're using the euclidean metric for our
measurement
so now we've created a model here's our
live model we fitted the data to it we
say hey here's our training data
let's go ahead and predict it so we're
going to take our y predict equals k
n predict y test so this is data we have
not this model has not seen this data
and so we're going to create a whole new
set of data off of there
now before we look at our prediction in
fact let's
i'm going to bring this down and put it
back in here later
let's take a look at our x test data
versus the y
test what does it look like and so we
have
our mean area we're going to compare it
to our mean compactness
we're going to go ahead and run that and
we can see here the data if you look at
this
just eyeballing it let me put it in here
we have
a lot of blue here and we have a lot of
orange here
and so these dots in the middle
especially like this one here
and these here these are the ones that
are going to give us
false negatives and so we should expect
this is your noise this is where we're
not sure what it is
and then b9 is in this case is done in
blue
and malignant is done in one so if you
look at
it there's two points based on these
features
which makes it really hard to have a
hundred percent where the hundred
percent is down here
um or up here that's kind of thing i'd
be looking for when we're talking
about cancer and stuff like that where
you really don't want any
uh false negatives you want everything
false positive great you're gonna go in
there and have another
set up in there where you might get a
get a autopsy or something like that
done on it
again that's very data specific on here
so now let's go ahead and pull in and
get our our prediction in here and we'll
create our y prediction
we'll go and run that so now this is
loaded with what we think
the unknown data is going to be and we
can go ahead and take that
and go and plot it because it's always
nice to have some pretty pictures
and when we plot it we're going to do
the mean area versus mean compactness
again you look at this map and you can
see
that there's some clear division here we
can clearly say on some of the stuff
that our y prediction if we look at this
map up here
and this map down here we probably got
some pretty good deal it looks pretty
good like they match a lot
this is of course just eyeballing it
really you don't want to eyeball these
things
you want to show people the pictures so
they can see it you can say hey this is
what it looks like
but we really want the confusion matrix
and we do the y
test and the y predict we can see in the
confusion matrix here
it did pretty good and we'll just go
ahead and point that out real quick
here's our 42 which is positive
and our 79 and if i remember correctly
i'd have to look at the data which one
of these is a false negative
i believe it's the nine that's scary i
would not want to be one of those nine
people told that i don't have cancer and
then
suddenly find out i do so we would need
to find a way to sort
this out and there is different ways to
do that a little bit past this but you
can start messing with
the actual euclidean geometry and the
activation
measurements and start changing those
and how they
interact but that's very advanced
there's also other ways to classify them
or to create a whole another class right
here of
we don't knows those are just a couple
of the solutions you might use for that
but for a lot of things this works out
great
you can see here you know maybe you're
trying to sell something well if this
was not
uh life dependent and this was if i
display this ad 42 of these people are
going to buy it
and if i display this other ad if i
don't display it
79 people are going to go a different
direction or whatever it is so maybe
you're trying to display whether they're
going to buy something if you add it on
to the website
in which case that's really a good
numbers you've just added a huge number
of cells to your company
so that was our k nearest neighbors uh
let's go ahead and take a look at
support
vector machines so support vector
machines
is the main objective of a support
vector machine algorithm is to find a
hyperplane in an n dimensional space
n is the number of features that
distinctly classifies the data points
if you remember we were just looking at
those nice graphs we had earlier in fact
let me go ahead and flip back on over
there
if we were looking at this data here we
might want to try to find
a nice line through the data and that's
what we're talking about
with this next setup so the main
objective support vector machine
algorithm is to find a hyperplane in an
n-dimensional space n is a number of
features
that distinctly classifies the data
points to separate the two classes of
data
there are many hyperplanes that can be
chosen
our objective is to find the plane that
has the maximum margin
i.e the maximum distance between data
points of both
classes the dimensions of the hyperplane
depends on the number of features
if there are two input features then the
hyperplane is just a line
if there are three features then the
hyperplane becomes a two dimensional
plane
the line that separates the data into
two classes is called
as support vector classifier
or hard margin that's why i just showed
you on the other data you can see here
we look for a line that splits the data
evenly
the problem with hard margin is that it
doesn't allow
outliers and doesn't work with
non-linearly
separable data and we just were looking
at that let me flip back on over here
and when we look at this setup in here
and we look at this data
here we go look how many outliers are in
here these are all with all these blue
dots on the wrong side of the line would
be considered an outlier
and the same with the red line and so it
becomes very difficult to divide this
data unless there's a clear
space there we go therefore we introduce
soft margins which accept the new data
point
and optimize a model for non-linear data
points
soft margins pass through the data
points at the border of the classes
the support vector machine can be used
to separate the two classes of shapes
here we can see that although triangles
and diamond shapes
have pointy edges but we are able to
classify them in two categories using a
support vector machine
let's go ahead and see what that looks
like in a demo flip back on over to our
jupiter notebook
we always want to start with taking a
look at the sk
learn api in this case the
svm svc there is a significant number of
parameters
because sk the svm has been a lot of
development in the recent years and has
become very popular
if we scroll all the way down to methods
you'll see right here as our fit
and our predict that's what you should
see in most of the
scikit learn packages so this should
look very familiar to what we've already
been working on
and we'll go ahead and bring in our
import
and run that we should already have
pandas numpy our matplot library which
we're going to be using to graph some of
the things
a little bit different right here you'll
see that we're going to go ahead and
bring in
one of the fun things you can do with
test data is
make circles circles are really hard to
classify
you have a ring on the inside and a ring
on the outside and you can see where
that can cause some issues and we'll
take a look at that a little closer in a
minute
here's our svm setup on there
and then of course our metrics because
we're going to use that to take a closer
look at things
so we go and run this whoops i already
did once we've gone ahead and done that
we're going to go ahead
and start making ourselves some data
and this part probably a little bit more
complicated than we need
i'm not going to go too much in detail
on it we're going to make a mesh grid
and we'll see what that looks like in a
minute we're defining the minimums
you can see in here create a measuring
points here's our parameters
of x y and h it's going to return x x y
y
you can also send a note to us make sure
you get a copy of this if you want to
dig deeper
into this particular code especially and
we have a ymin ymax
ymin y max plus one here's our mesh grid
we're actually going to make xx and yy
plot the contours all the way through
and this is just
a way of creating data it's kind of a
fun way to create some data
we go plot contours a x l f x x y y
and return it out add some perimeters
here
so that when we're doing it we have our
setup on there
train property and then we'll go ahead
and make our data
just throw that right in there too in
the same setup and run that
so now we have x and y we're going to
make our circles we have n
samples equal samples in this case we're
going to have 500 samples
we went ahead and gave it a noise of
0.05 random state 123.
these are all going into let's go back
up
here we go make our mesh grid make
circles
there it is uh so this is going into our
make circles up here
and this is part of that setup on this
and then once we've gone ahead and make
the circle let's go ahead and plot it
that way you can see we're talking about
right now what i'm saying is really
confusing because without a visual it
doesn't really mean very much
what we're actually doing so i'm going
to run this with the plot let's go back
up here and just take a look
we've made our circle we have our end
samples equal samples we're going to
have 500 we're going to have training
property 0.8
here's our data frame we go and load it
into the data frame so we can plot it
groups df group by label this is kind of
a fun way if you have multiple
columns you can really quickly pull
whatever setup is in there
and then we go ahead and plot it and you
can see here we have
two rings that are formed and that's all
this is doing is just making this data
for us
this is really hard data to figure out a
lot of programs get confused in this
because there's no straight line or
anything like that
but we can add planes and different
setups on here
and so you can see we have some very
interesting data we have our zero is in
blue and our ones in the yellow in the
middle
and the data points are an x y
coordinate plot on this
one of the things we might want to do on
here is go ahead and
find the min to max ratio
set up in there and we can even do let's
just do a print x you can see what the
data looks like that we're producing
on this there we go so x equals
x minus x min over x max minus
x min all we're doing is putting this
between zero and one
whatever this data is we want a zero to
one set up
on here and if you look at this all our
data is 0.8.5
that's what this particular line is
doing that's a pretty common thing to do
in processing data especially in neural
networks
neural networks don't like big numbers
they create huge biases and cause all
kinds of problems
and that's true in a lot of our models
some of the models it doesn't really
matter
but when you're doing enough of these
you just start doing them
you just start putting everything
between zero and one there's even some
algorithms to do that in the sk
learn although it's pretty as you can
see it's pretty easy to do it here so
let's go ahead and jump into the next
thing which is a linear
kind of setup c equals 1.0 this is the
svm regularization
parameter we're going to use models
here's our svm
and this one's scroll up just a notch
there we go
so here we are with our model we're
going to create the
the setup with the svc kernel is linear
and we'll come back to that because
that's an important uh
setup in there as far as what our kernel
is and you'll you'll see why that's so
important here in a minute
because we're going to look at a couple
of these and so this one is we're
actually going to be changing how that
processes it
uh and then our c here's our one our
point o and then the rest of this
is uh plotting we're just adding titles
making the contours so it's a pretty
graph you can actually spend
this would be a whole class just to do
all the cool things you can do with
scatter plots and regular plots and
colors and things like that
in this case we're going to create a
graph with a nice white line down the
middle so that you can see what's going
on here
and when we do this you can see that as
it
is a split the data the linear did just
that it drew a line through the data
and it says this is supposed to be blue
and this is supposed to be red
and it doesn't really fit very well
that's because we used a linear division
of the data and it's not very linear
data on
uh is anything but linear so when we
we look at that it's like well okay that
didn't work what's the next option
well there's a lot of choices in here
one of them is just simply we can change
this from the kernel being linear
to poly and we'll just go back up here
and use the same chart
oops here we go so here we go linear
kernel
we'll change this to poly and then when
we come in here and create our model
here's our model up here linear we can
actually just go right in and change
this to the poly model
and if you remember we go back over here
to the svc and let's scroll back
up here there's a lot of different
options oops even further
okay so we come up here and we start
talking about the kernel here's the
kernel there's linear there's poly rbf
sigmoid pre-computed there's a lot of
different ways to
do this setup and their actual default
is rbf
very important to note that so when
you're running these models
understanding which parameter is really
has a huge effect on what's going
on in this particular one with the svm
the kernel is so important you really
need to know that
and we switched our kernel to poly and
when we run this
you can see it's changed a little bit we
now have a quite an interesting looking
diagram
and you can see on here it now has
these classifications correct but it
messes up
in this blue up here and it messes up on
this blue is correct and this blue is
supposed to be red
you can see that it still isn't quite
fitting on there and so
that is uh when we do a poly fit
you can see if you have a split in data
where there's a group in the middle
that's one kind of data
and the groups on the outside are
different the polyfit
or the poly kernel is what's going to be
fit for that
so if that doesn't work then what are we
going to use
well they have the rbf kernel and let's
go ahead and take a look and see what
the rbf looks like
and let me go and turn there we go turn
my drawing off
and the rbf kernel oops there we go rbf
and then of course for our title it's
always nice to have it match with the
r b f kernel let me go ahead and run
this
and you can see that the rbf kernel does
a really good job
uh it actually has divided the data up
on here and this
is the kind of what you expect here was
that ring here's our inner ring
and an outer ring of data and so the rbf
fits this data package quite nicely
and that we talk about svm it really is
powerful in that it has
this kind of sorting feature to it in
its algorithms
this is something that is really hard to
get the sk
means to do or the k-means setup and so
when you start looking at these
different
machine learning algorithms
understanding your data and how it's
grouped is really important it makes a
huge
difference as far as what you're
computing and what you're doing with it
so that was a demo on the support vector
uh certainly you could have done
continued on that and done like a
confusion matrix and all that kind of
fun stuff to see how good it was and
split the data up to see how it uh
vectorizes the visual on that's so
important it makes a big difference just
to see
what it looks like and that giant donut
and why it does circle so well
or your poly version or your linear
version so we've looked at
some very numerical kind of setups where
there's a lot of math involved euclidean
geometry
that kind of thing a totally different
machine learning algorithm for
approaching this
is the decision trees and there's also
forests that go with the decision trees
they're based on multiple trees combined
the decision tree is a supervised
learning algorithm used for
classification
it creates a model that predicts a value
of a target variable by learning simple
decision rules inferred from the data
features
a decision tree is a hierarchical tree
structure
where an internal node represents
features or tribute
the branch represents a decision rule
and each leaf node represents the
outcome and you can see here where they
have the first one
yes or no and then you go either left or
right and so forth
one of the coolest things about decision
trees
is and i'll see people actually run a
decision tree even though their final
model is different because the decision
tree allows you to see what's going on
you can actually look at it and say
why did you go right or left what was
the choice where's that break
and that is really nice if you're trying
to share that information with somebody
else as to
why when you start getting into the why
this is happening
decision trees are very powerful so the
topmost note of a decision tree is known
as the
root note it learns to partition
on the basis of the attribute value it
partitions the tree in a recursive
manner so you have your decision node if
you get yes
you go down to the next note that's a
decision note and either yes you go to
if it ends on a leaf node then you know
your answer
which is yes or no so there's your
there's your in classification set up on
there here's an example of a decision
tree that tells whether
i'll sleep or not at a particular
evening mine would be depending on
whether i have the news on or not
do i need to sleep no okay i'll work
uh yes is it raining outside yes
i'll sleep no i'll work so i guess if
it's uh
not raining outside it's harder to fall
asleep whether you have that nice
rain coming in and again this is really
cool about a decision tree is i can
actually look at it and go oh
i like to sleep when it rains outside so
when you're looking at all the data you
can say oh this is where the twitch
comes in
when it rains outside i'll sleep really
good if it's not raining or if i don't
need sleep then i'm not going to sleep
i'm going to go work
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that that looks like in the code
just like we did before we go ahead and
open up the site kit
set up just to say what the decision
tree classifier has
you have your parameters which we'll
look a little bit more in depth at as we
write the code
but it has different ways of splitting
it
the strategy used to choose a split at
each node
criterion max depth remember the tree
how far down do you want it do you want
to take up
the space of your whole computer with an
and map
every piece of data or you know the
smaller that number is
the smaller the level the tree is and
the less processing it takes but it's
also more general so you're less likely
to get as in depth and answer
um and then of course minimal samples
you need for it to split samples for the
leaves there's a lot of things in here
as far as what how big the tree is and
how to define it and when do you define
it and how to weight it
and they have their different attributes
which you can dig deeper into
that can be very important if you want
to know the why of things
and then we go down here to our methods
and you'll see just like everything else
we have our fit method
very important and our predict the two
main things that we use what is we're
going to predict our x to be equal to
and we'll go ahead and go up here and
start putting together the code
we're going to import our numpy our
pandas there's our confusion matrix
our train test split decision tree
classifier that's the big one that we're
actually working with
that's the line right here where we're
going to be oops decision tree there it
is decision tree
classifier that's the one i was looking
for and of course we want to know the
accuracy in the classification report on
here
and we're going to do a little different
than we did in the other examples
and there's a reason for this let me go
and run this and load this up here
we're going to go ahead and build things
on functions and this is
when you start splitting up into a team
this is the kind of thing you start
seeing a lot more
both in teams and for yourself because
you might want to swap one data to test
it on a different data depending on
what's going on
so we're going to have our import data
here the data set length the balance
and so forth this just returns balanced
data let me just go ahead and print
because i'm curious as to what this
looks like import
data and it's going to return the
balance data so if i run that
if we go ahead and print this out here
and run that
you can see that we have a whole bunch
of data that comes in there
and some interesting setup on here has
uh
let's see brr i'm not sure exactly what
that represents on here
uh one one one one one two and so forth
so
we have a different set of data here the
shape is uh five columns
one two three four five uh seems to have
a number at the beginning
which i'm gonna guess brl a letter i
mean
and then a bunch of numbers in there 1 1
1 1 let's see down here we got 555
set up on this and let's see balance
data
and since it said balance data i'm going
to guess that b means
balanced r means you need to move it
right and l means it's
needs to be moved left or skewed to the
left i'm not sure which one ah let's go
and close that out
and we'll go ahead and create a function
to split the data set
x balance data equals data values
white balance equals data values of zero
there's that letter remember left right
balance then we're looking for the
values of one through five
and we go ahead and split it just like
you would x train y train set random
state 100
test size is 0.3 so we're taking 30 of
the data
and it's going to return your x your y
your y train your
uh your x train your x test your y train
your
y test again we do this because if
you're running a lot of these
you might want to switch how you split
the data and how you train it
i tend to use a bifold method i'll take
a third of the data
and i'll train it on the other two
thirds and test it on that third
and then i'll switch it i'll switch
which third is a test data
and then i can actually take that
information and correlate it and it
gives me a really robust
package for figuring out what the
complete accuracy is
but in this case we're just going to go
ahead this is our function for splitting
data
and this is where it kind of gets
interesting because remember we're
talking a little bit about
the different settings in our model
and so uh in here we're going to create
a
decision tree but we're going to use the
genie set up and where did that come
from
uh what's the genie on here so if we go
back to the top of their page
and we have what criterion are we going
to use we're going to use
genie they have genie and entropy those
are the two main ones that they use for
the decision tree
so this one's going to be genie and if
we're going to have a function that
creates
the genie model and it even goes down
here and here's our fit
train of the genie model uh we'll
probably also want to
create one for entropy sometimes i even
just i might even make this just one
function
with the different setups and i know one
of my one of the things i worked on
recently i had to
create a one that tested across multiple
models
and so i would send the parameters to
the models or i would
send this part right here which says
decision tree classifier
that whole thing might be what i send to
create the model
and i know it's going to fit we're going
to have our x train and we're going to
have our predict and all that stuff is
the same
so you can just send that model to your
function
for testing different models again this
just gives you one of the ways to do it
and you can see here we're going to
chain train with the genie and we're
also going to
cha train with the entropy to see how
that works
and if you're going to have your models
going two separate models you're sending
there
we'll go ahead and create a prediction
this simply is our y predict equals
r uh whatever object we sent whatever
model we sent here the cllf
object and predict against our x test
and you can see here print y predict and
return y predict
set up on here we'll load that
definition up and then if you're going
to have
a function that runs a predict and print
some things out
we should also have our accuracy
function so
here's our calculate the accuracy what
are we sending we're sending our y
test data this could also be y actual
and y predict and then we'll print out a
confusion matrix
then we'll print out the accuracy of the
score on here
and print a report classification report
bundle it all together there
so if we bring this all together we have
all the steps we've been working towards
which
is importing our data by the ways you'll
spend 80 percent of your time importing
data in most
machine learning setups and cooking it
and burning it and getting it formatted
so that it
works with whatever models you're
working with the decision tree
has some cool features in that if you're
missing data
it can actually pick that up and just
skip that and says i don't know how to
split
this there's no way of knowing whether
it rained or didn't rain last night
so i'll look at something else like
whether you watched tv after eight
o'clock you know that blue screen thing
so we have our function importing our
data set we bring in the data we split
the data so we have
our x text test and y train and then we
have our
different models our clf genie so it's a
decision tree classifier using the genie
setup
and then we can also create the model
using entropy
and then once we have that we have our
function for making the prediction
and we have our function for calculating
the accuracy
and then if we're going to have that we
should probably have our main code
involved here
this probably looks more familiar if
you're depending on what you're working
on if you're working on like a
pie charm then you would see this in
throwing something up real quick in
jupiter notebook
uh so here's our our main data
import which we've already defined we
get our split data
we create our genie we create our
entropy so there's our two models going
on here
there's our two models so these are two
separate data models
we've already sent them to be trained
then we're going to go ahead and
print the results using genie index so
we'll start with the genie
and we want to go ahead with the genie
and print our
our predictions yx test to the genie
and calculate the accuracy on here and
then we want to print the results using
entropy
so this is just the same thing coming
down like we did with the genie we're
going to
put out our y predict entropy and our
calculations
so let's go ahead and run that and just
see what this uh piece of code does
uh we do have like one of our data needs
to be is getting a warning on there
that's nothing major because it's just a
simple warning
probably an update of new versions
coming out uh and so here we are we have
our data set it's got 625
you can actually see an example of the
data set b
meaning balanced i guess and here's our
five data points one one one one means
it's balanced
it's skewed to the right with one one
one two uh and so forth on here
and then we're going to go ahead and
predict from our prediction whether it's
to the right or to the left you could
think of a washing machine that's
banging on one side of the thing or
maybe it's an automated car
where we're down the middle of the road
that's in balance and it starts going
veering to the right so we need to
correct for it
and when we print out the confusion
matrix we have three different variables
r l and b so we should through the three
different variables on here
and you have as far as whether it
predicts
in this case the balance there's not a
lot of balanced loads on here
and didn't do a good job guessing
whether it's balanced or not that's what
i took from this first one
the second one i'm guessing is the right
so
it did pretty good job guessing the
right balance you can see that a bunch
of them came up left unbalanced
probably not good for an automated car
as it tells you 18 out of the
uh 18 missed things and tells you to go
the wrong direction
and here we are going the other way 19
to 71.
and of course we can back that up with
an accuracy
report on here and you can see the
precision how well the left and right
balances
79 79 precision and so forth
and then we went and used the entropy
and let me just see if we can get
so we can get them both next to each
other here's our entropy of our
the first set up our first model which
is the genie model
67 18 1971 63
22 2070 pretty close
the two models you know that's not a
huge difference in numbers
this second one of entropy did slightly
it looks like slightly
worse because it did one better as far
as
the right balance and did what is this
four worse on the left balance or
whatever so slightly worse
if i was guessing between these i'd
probably use the first one
they're so close though that wouldn't be
it wouldn't be a clear choice as to
which one worked better
and there's a lot of numbers you can
play with here which might give better
results depending on what the data is
going
in now one of the takeaways you should
have
from the different category
routines we ran is that they run very
similar
you certainly change the perimeters in
them as to whether you're using what
model you're using and how you're using
it and what data they get applied to
but when you're talking about the scikit
learn package it does such an awesome
job of making it easy
you split your data you train your data
and you run the prediction and then you
see what kind of accuracy
what can confusion confusion matrix it
generates
so um we talk about algorithm selection
logistic regression k nearest neighbors
logistic regression is used when we have
a binomial outcome
for example to predict whether an email
is spam or not whether the tumor is
malignant or not
the logistic regression works really
good on that you can do it in the
k-nearest neighbors also
the question is which one will it work
better in i find the logistic regression
models work really good
in a lot of raw numbers so if you're
working with say the stock market
is this a good investment or a bad
investment
so that's one of the things that it
handles the numbers better k
nearest neighbors are used in scenarios
where non-parametric no fixed number of
perimeters
algorithms are required it is used in
pattern recognition
data mining and intrusion detection
so k means really good in finding the
patterns
i've seen that as a preprocessor to a
lot of other processors where you use
the k
nearest neighbors to figure out what
data groups together
very powerful package support vector
machines
support vector machines are used
whenever the data has higher dimensions
the human genome micro array svms are
extensively used in the hard
handwriting recognition models and you
can see that we were able to
switch between the parabolic and the
circular setup on there where you can
now
have that donut kind of data and be able
to filter that out with the support
vector machine
and then decision trees are mostly used
in operational researches
specifically decision analysis to help
identify a strategy most likely to reach
any goal
they are preferred where the model is
easy to understand
i like that last one it's a good
description is it easy to understand
so you have data coming in when am i
going to go to bed you know was it
raining outside
you can go back and actually look at the
pieces and see those different decision
modes
takes a little bit more to dig in there
and figure out what they're doing but
you can do that and you can actually
help you
figure out why people love it for the y
factor so strengths and limitations
big one on all of these the strengths
and limitations we talk about logistic
the strings are it is easy to implement
and efficient to train
it is relatively easy to regularize the
data points
remember how we put everything between
zero and one when you look at logistic
regression models
you don't have to worry about that as
much limitations as a high reliance on
proper
representation of data they could only
predict a categorical outcome
with the k nearest neighbors it doesn't
need a separate
training period new data can be added
seamlessly without affecting the
accuracy of the model
kind of an interesting thing because you
can do partial training that can become
huge if you're worrying across
really large data sets or the data is
coming in it can continually
do a partial fit on the data with the k
nearest neighbors and continue to adjust
that data
it doesn't it doesn't work on high
dimensional and large
data sets we were looking at the breast
cancer
36 different features what happens when
you have 127
features or a million features and you
say well what do you have a million
features in
well if i was analyzing uh logic
the legal documents i might have a
tokenizer that splits the words up to be
analyzed and that tokenizer might create
one million
different words available that might be
in the document for doing weights
uh sensitive to noisy data outliers and
missing values
that's a huge one with k nearest
neighbors they really don't know what to
do with the missing value how do you
compute the
the distance if you don't know what the
value is uh the svm
works more efficiently on high
dimensional data
it is relatively memory efficient so
it's able to create those planes with
only a few
different variables in there as opposed
to having to store a lot of data for
different
features and things like that it's not
suitable for a large data sets
the svm you start running this over
gigabytes of data causes some huge
issues
underperforms if the data has noise or
overlapping
that's a big one we were looking at that
where the svm
splits it and it creates a soft buffer
but what happens when you have a lot of
stuff in the middle
that's hard to sort out and doesn't know
what to do with that causes svm to start
crashing or not perform as well
decision trees handles non-linear
perimeters and missing values
efficiently the missing values is huge
i've seen this in was it the wine
tasting data sets where they have three
different data sets
and they share certain features but then
each one has some features that aren't
in the other ones
and has to figure out how to handle
those well the decision tree does that
automatically
instead of having to figure a way to
fill that data in before processing like
you would with the other models
it's easy to understand and has less
training period so it trains pretty
quickly
comes up there and just keeps forking
the tree down and moving the parts
around
and so it doesn't have to go through the
data multiple times
guessing and adjusting it just creates
the tree as it goes
overfitting and high variance are the
most annoying part of it
that's that's an understatement that has
to do with how many leaves and how many
decisions you have it do
the more you have the more overfit it is
to the data
it also uh just in making the choices
and how the choices come in
it might overfit to a specific feature
because that's where it started at and
that's what it knows
and it really is challenged with large
data sets
they've been working on that with the
data forest but it's not suitable for
large data sets it's really something
you'd probably run on a single machine
and not across
not across a data pool or anything
so that wraps it up today thank you for
joining us at simplylearn
for more information please visit
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here